eu vim perguntar qual é o valor da arte
é como é que a gente sabe se uma música
é boa independente do nosso gosto porque
ultimamente tem uma parcela enorme da
população brasileira e mundial que
associa imediatamente sucesso à
qualidade é e até uma parte da crítica
contra uma história aconteceu comigo
quando morreu um jovem cantor sertanejo
há pouco tempo num acidente de automóvel
é ter uma comoção nacional né programa
de televisão é filas para o enterro e eu
nunca tinha ouvido falar do nome desse
desse cantor sertanejo e ao normal hoje
em dia é porque antigamente todo mundo
via televisão aberta hoje na televisão
fechada paga pela internet tem um monte
de coisas pessoas num formam-se nichos
diferentes na então é normal você não
conhecer tudo e quando eu falei dessa
minha ignorância na minha página na rede
social eu comecei a ser atacado pelos
fãs desse desse cantor e é normal porque
vem da palavra fanático em alguns
fanáticos são violentos mesmo mas o que
me causou estranheza foi um dos
argumentos porque me atacavam é porque
como o sucesso é um catalisador da
qualidade
se eu não conhecia quase como se
estivesse sendo que ele é ruim né e as
críticas eram todas assim quem é você
pra falar dele quantas músicas de
sucesso e tem na parada agora qual o
tamanho do seu show agora
ou seja ele faz mais sucesso faz mais
dinheiro é melhor que você é e quando as
pessoas vêm nas minhas redes sociais
também por algum motivo político me
atacar em geral ataca desse mesmo jeito
falando do dinheiro que está sendo
gerado do sucesso que está acontecendo
então passou a ser um analisador mesmo
de qualidade só que o sucesso não tem
nada a ver com qualidade e sucesso e
sorte é acaso né é uma música boa para
eles essa música ruim pode fazer sucesso
na música boa pode não fazer sucesso
também estão sendo não é
não existe uma relação direta é o que eu
sinto é que a gente vive numa sociedade
pós moderna em que os valores humanistas
feito amor ao conhecimento à cultura a
natureza razão amor ao próximo
passaram a ser considerados velhos
ineficientes antiquadas
é como se o ar ideologia neoliberal
tivesse conquistado não só o poder mas
as nossas almas a gente tivesse que ter
alma e eficientes almas competitivas
poucos solidárias né e só que a arte ea
alma mas não são empresas não tem que
dar lucro a arte não foi inventada para
dar lucro não foi inventada para ser
eficiente é mas foi sempre essencial
a arte foi inventada antes de tudo que a
gente conhece já se fazia desenhos nas
paredes das cavernas já se fazia música
a música anterior à agricultura então
muito anterior ao comércio muito
anterior à propriedade privada mas
acabou se tudo sendo mercantilizado
então vou contar mais ou menos na música
como s chegou ao máximo a
mercantilização que acontece hoje
começou nos estados unidos nos anos 70
até os anos 70 tinha uma multiplicidade
de selos eram seus pequenos e os donos
dos selos e um atrás de talentos e eles
descobriram vários tipos de de músicas
então o carro acelera especializado num
estilo tinha um botão destaques que era
mais música negra mas tinha diversas no
seu cara que descobriu o ovo presley é
uma multiplicidade de de música e de
selos com o tempo esses selos foram
sendo vendidos para as gravadoras
absurdo se fundindo os gravadores foram
sendo vendidas para é a grandes
conglomerados de mídia time warner foi
vendida para time ver o time warner e
esse conglomerado de mídia tinham sede
um wall street
eles não tinham nenhuma preocupação
cultural não tava nem atrás de talento
atrás de lucro e aí a música passou a
ser dominada não mais pelos diretores
artísticos mas pelos diretores de
marketing e diretores de venda ea música
começou
a e relevante é a música era apresentada
principalmente no final dos anos 90 e
começo dos anos 2000 com música pop era
muito inferior em termos de atrativo
para a alma do que a música era feita
antes porque a intenção era outra e
quando chegou à internet
esse monopólio desapareceu muito por
conta das gravadoras já serem relevantes
naquele momento as grandes carreiras
estão se tornando independentes ninguém
estava preocupado em manter os lucros
das gravadoras elas ficaram tentaram
puniu os usuários porque tinha músicas
piratas foi um grande movimento para
tentar conter o futuro mas não teve não
teve mais jeito é eu como artista
conheci essa ascensão e queda do império
das gravadoras aqui no brasil
quando eu comecei início dos anos 80 é
até porque quando a gente vive num
momento de ditadores de concentração de
renda no país se vendia muito pouco
disso então os grandes artistas
eles vendiam saná 20 mil 30 mil discos
mas não era um problema ele são
carreiras sólidas consolidadas
ninguém pensava que ela tinha que vender
um milhão não é ser mandado embora da
gravadora caetano veloso gilberto gil
chico buarque nenhum deles somente disco
de ouro e eram os artistas que não
representavam aqui é alimentava a nossa
alma de beleza de cultura
eu me lembro quando fui contratado pela
warner
o kid abelha ainda de um dia tá
conversando com o presidente da
gravadora vendo aqueles montes de discos
que eram os discos da minha vida eu
ainda era um garoto não sabe o que está
fazendo ali ia perguntando quanto vendeu
esse aqui quanto e era sempre ridículo a
gente no primeiro compacto vendeu muito
mais do que aqueles discos todos ali e e
e rock
foi a primeira grande monocultura da
indústria brasileira que ela começou a
se adaptar o que estava vivendo os
estados unidos já que era buscar o lucro
o rock vendeu é inacreditavelmente mais
do que tudo que você vendendo antes e se
o cara podia ter
na primeira canção de uma banda que foi
o caso por exemplo do que já beira o da
blitz no que foi o primeiro grande
fenômeno que vendeu 250 mil compactos de
você não soube me amar quando lançou o
disco também vender o disco de ouro
então se a gravadora podia ter o grana
de volta na primeira música pra que que
iria estimular as carreiras né
antes do do rock tinha uma até durante
no comecinho do rock ainda tinha uma
expectativa de fracasso dos primeiros
discos do artista
o primeiro disco era com certeza um
fracasso mas colocava aquele artista no
mercado
o segundo disco e já dava alguma
credibilidade
o oeste já era um pouco mais conhecido
se desce sorte não dava prejuízo se
pagava a partir do terceiro se esperava
que pudesse começar a dar lucro e
grandes carreiras foram sendo
construídos
mas eo a indústria vê uma possibilidade
de abortar esse tempo todo e partiu
direto para o lucro
eu me lembro compondo uma vez na casa do
vinícius cantuária para algum artista
novo tem alguma gravadora queria lançar
naquela época e é um diretor artístico
da gravadora ligou para o vinícius falou
'vem cá como é que tá indo aí tudo certo
o mano vai fazer aquelas coisas chatas
que você faz com o chico buarque tá pra
você ver como é que a qualidade não
tinha a menor diferença né
aliás era mal vista a qualidade podia
atrapalhar
e aí quando eles perceberam isso eles
começaram a descobrir também o rock não
era tão lucrativo assim muito mais
lucrativa zonas populares e aí começou
várias ondas que excluíam todo o resto
quando vim à lambada era só lambada ou
achei ela só axé sertanejo pagode e
depois pagode universitário sertanejo
universitário série de ondas que em que
eles procuravam os artistas que já
tinham público que já estavam prontos e
que já iam dá lucro
e foi exatamente aí que o mercado
começou a fazer água
quando as vendas explodirão brasil acho
que a década de 90 foi a mais lucrativa
que dependam mais risco foi que a
indústria começou a perder valor e as
pessoas não iam mais para as lojas
procuram o disco daqueles artista
favorito não tinha diz o próximo da
legião o que vai dizer
a minha vida o próximo do zero quando
era novo né
já não tinha isso era só legal essa
música mas já num mundial funcionava a
nossa vida mais a eu tinha uma banda são
heróis da resistência depois do kid
abelha e já pegou esse a saladeira baixa
do rock ea gente foi vendo a coisa
definhar
eu começo ainda lançou um disco solo em
1993 que tinha garotos 2 música estourou
no brasil inteiro mas vendeu pouco
vendeu pouco vendeu mais do que aqueles
discos que eu perguntei na parede
enquanto vendia e eu fui escurraçado da
gravadora só vende isso e eram artistas
que vendiam isso quando comecei então
meio difícil de entender
aí quando veio o napster foi o auge
disso é que foi quando apareceram os
sites pixelpipe você podia compartilhar
música com quem estivesse conectado com
você
as gravadoras não faziam sentido eles
resolveram brigar com o napster onde
estavam todos os consumidores deles é
que nenhuma empresa de fabricar sapatos
começar a processar todo mundo que gosta
de sapato né
é uma coisa meio maluca mas foi um mal
que veio para o bem porque por conta
disso eles acabaram perdendo esse
monopólio de produção e distribuição de
música e os artistas ficaram livres para
fazer o que quiser e para mais artistas
poderem entrar porque eles eram gargalo
bem pequenininho
naquela época você tinha gravadora você
é invisível ness e independente é
independente do público também e aí essa
liberdade que os artistas passaram a ter
provocar uma diversidade que a gente não
conhece mas vou procurar na internet
hoje a música é muito mais rica e muito
mais diversa do que era o que a gente
pode aproveitar outros retornos que o
pessoal falar vocês do marfim é de grana
artista a maior parte das chances de
pobre né ea maior parte dos agentes não
faz isso porque dá dinheiro faz porque
ama de verdade esses outros retornos
começaram a aparecer não falar de
algumas músicas minhas que são pra mim
mais importantes do que músicas que me
deram muito dinheiro
me deram muita projeção a primeira que
vou falar sobre fotografia que eu fiz
com léo jaime e que ela fala sobre
amizade e sobre a felicidade no dia
dia e você reconhece que no passado num
momento que você nem se tocou que estava
sendo feliz é aconteceu recebi um e-mail
uma vez é da época do orkut alguma coisa
assim de uma pessoa que tinha perdido o
irmão e um ano depois da morte de uma
família se reuniu
não foi uma missa não foi uma cerimônia
religiosa ele simplesmente se abraçaram
e ouviram fotografia em silêncio e
aquele momento foi um momento muito
reconfortante pra eles e saber disso pra
mim foi assim agora como compositor
saber que eu pude ajudar uma família que
eu nem conhecia uma música que não foi
direcionada para eles e depois dessa
canção passou a ser uma canção tema de
infinitas formaturas toda hora outras
pessoas falar a música no formato da
minha formatura foi fotografia
ela passou a fazer parte da vida
daquelas pessoas que se formaram é de um
jeito muito mais é permanente do que uma
música só tocou no rádio outra canção
pra mim é muito importante é temporada
das flores que alguns que fala sobre
sair da depressão e muita gente que teve
depressão já me deu depoimento super
emocionados de como essa canção ajudou
eles a atravessar esse momento e de como
aquilo virava um mantra
uma outra pessoa também mandou e mail
falou que teve um câncer muito agressivo
e enquanto ela se tratando ficava
ouvindo a música como uma esperança de
que teria uma temporada das flores no
futuro e quando ela se curou
aquilo virou um amuleto então continuou
vindo como amuleto uma lembrança de como
ela tinha se recuperado daqueles tempos
tão difíceis
uma outra canção importante pra mim é
melhor pra mim
a primeira canção de amor que eu fiz pra
minha mulher e que virou também uma
música tema de pedidos de casamento
as pessoas aprendem a tocar música para
cantar os seus pretendidos né e aí eu já
já realizei vários pedidos de casamento
no palco por causa disso as pessoas em
contato comigo pela internet falou quero
pedir minha mulher em casamento eu quero
pedir meu nome já teve até casamento
entre duas meninas também que a pessoa
se sobe no palco e cantou e depois que
acabam sempre vem aqui aí se ajoelha da
aliança
foi super bonito pra mim é uma música
que o meu amor ficou representado nas
outras pessoas também em outra situação
importante também foi quando fui tocar
no hospital sarah de brasília
o hospital público e é um hospital muito
interessante que eles tenham um teatro
ali dentro em que as pessoas podem
chegar de maca
estamos tratando tomar com soro na veia
estão assistindo o show chegou de
cadeira de rodas
você toca para o o os internos ea a
doutora lúcia que a neurocientista muito
famosa e também é diretor presidente da
rede falou que no dia que tem evento
artístico ali eles aplicam 50% - já não
gesicka e as as altas aumenta em até 80%
então é legal é bom saber que cultura
além de dar um alívio na alma também
padalino corpo através da alma né
então eu queria terminar essa falante
tocar para vocês um pedacinho de uma
crônica do márcio tavares d'amaral que é
um escritor e professor de filosofia
chamada é como assim o humanismo uma das
marcas mais reconhecidas da cultura pós
moderna é seu anti humanismo
individualista o extremo o pós moderno é
um modo de estar no mundo que não
assimila a noção de valores humanos
transcendentes a existência corrido de
cada dia
o homem como valor está cassado hoje um
organismo grego o que propôs a formação
pela cultura para criar o homem afastar
o bárbaro herdamos dela como já vimos
herdado do humanismo judaico também
aprendemos no humanismo romano do
cidadão formulamos cristãmente a noção
universal de humanidade e distribuímos
pelos muitos cantos da terra humanismo
renascentista acabou afastando o homem
de deus e aproximando de outra grande
criatura a natureza e se humanismo
naturalista nos encheu de arte beleza e
prenunciou a época moderna a da razão
soberana a do homem público súditos
senhor da razão o pós-moderno
homem unidimensional consumista rompeu
com todos esses vínculos largou amarras
que iria ficar livre ficou à deriva
humanismo hoje não seria um saudosismo
passa a se passar dista nessa hora
crepuscular poderia ser um projeto
revolucionário e não tem mais tempo é
pra já
então eu vou tocar algumas músicas
comentei aqui
primeiro há a música da formatura
hoje o mar faz ondas feito criança no
balanço calma gente descansa
nessas horas dorme longe a lembrança de
ser feliz quando a tarde toma gente nos
braços sopra um vento que dissolve o
cansaço é o avesso do esforço que eu
faço pra ser feliz
o que vai ficar na fotografia
são laços e beijos gavia as cores que
duras no dia 11 o sol passando sobre os
amigos e história essa bebida e sorriso
ea fé
frente a alma
quando as sombras vão ficando cumpridas
em sendo a cada diz leslie e preguiça
nessas horas é que deus deixou as pistas
por eu ser feliz quando dia não passar
de um retrado colorindo de saudade o meu
arco
só aí vou ter certeza de fato eu fui
infeliz e vai ficar na rua toda
são os laços de viva e ska via as cores
figuras motivo o sol passando sobre os
amigos e histórias bebidas sorrisos em
que a fé em frente à alma
as flores pintura discutidos o sol
bastamos sobre os amigos e histórias
bebida e sorrisos ea fé do em frente à
alma
obrigado e agora música de sair da
depressão
que saudade agora me aguardem chegaram
as tardes de sol ameno pelas ruas flores
e amigos me contam vestindo o meu melhor
sorriso eu passei meu andam os muros
procurando não achar as respostas
eu era a causa ea saída de tudo eu cavei
como o túnel meu caminho de volta e
espera
o torcedor
depois do inverno
cores e espera amor
nossa temporada
isso
eu te trago um milhão de presentes e eu
achava que já tinha perdido mas estavam
na mesma gaveta e o calor das pessoas e
o amor pela vida e espero e estou
chegando com honre preparando campo ea
alma para as flores e quando ouvir
alguém falar meu nome eu te sul teve
pode acreditar
me espera
você
depois com inveja
flores e espera amor nossa perfurada das
espera
porque eu tô chegando depois do inferno
é rápida e dores e espera amor
nossa temporada
nada
que saudade agora me aguardem
chegaram as tardes de sol amigo
obrigado